[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo tout de suite les
titres de ce vendredi 12 avril
le grand débat national s'est achevée en
deux mois près d'1 25 million de
français y ont contribué
le temps des conclusions et est arrivé
nous ferons points dans les yvelines
avec notre chroniqueur seize mille
cahiers de doléances ont été répertoriés
l'exécutif s'est donné jusqu'à la mi
avril pour faire connaître ses décisions
pour parler de la fin de cette
consultation nous recevons les députés
la république en marge de la première
circonscription des yvelines
didier baichère insertion
professionnelle agriculture ou encore
visite des pompiers chesnais 10 comme
chaque vendredi et coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine
créer un lieu unique en france
à poissy de dimension internationale
dédiée aux arbitres et bénévoles de tous
niveaux et tous sports c'est le concept
du centre national de l'arbitrage et du
bénévolat de poissy il est actuellement
en préparation à l'initiative de la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise et de la municipalité
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude on parle pas seulement de ce qui
est le plus emblématique entre
guillemets le football de tous les
arbitres le handball le basket le judo
tous les arbitres de france vont pouvoir
élire domicile ici sur le territoire
dans un centre national de l'arbitrage
on viendra parler évidemment de leur
expertise leur ira également les efforts
mais on verra également les suivre
du point de vue médical ce centre
d'arbitrage sera situé au complexe
sportif marcel cerdan de poissy proche
de l'hôpital
le site pourrait servir à la préparation
des volontaires aux jeux olympiques de
les travaux devraient démarrer en
février 2020 avec pour objectif une
inauguration en septembre 2021
l'idée c'est vraiment créer un centre
multi fonctions avec des équipements
sportifs avec des salles de formation
des salles d'examen de l'hôtellerie de
la restauration et un centre de
recherche aussi surtout les nouvelles
technologies si un vrai besoin
aujourd'hui et au final il n'y a pas de
lieu dédié aux arbitres en france après
plus de quatre mois de crise des gilet
jaune
le grand débat s'achève le premier
ministre edouard philippe a présenté une
première synthèse des résultats lundi au
grand palais et a défendu l'initiative
devant les députés mardi 9 avril avec
nous en plateau pour en parler et didier
baichère député la rippe la république
en marge de la première circonscription
des yvelines
bonjour un jour également avec nous en
plateau notre journaliste de la
rédaction nicolas d'andry les jours
manon 1,5 million de français ont
contribué à ce grand débat mais
rapportée à 47 millions de français
inscrits sur les listes électorales il y
à un fossé peut-on vraiment parler de
grand débat didier baichère grand par la
participation oui bien sûr moi je pense
aux cinq cent mille personnes qui se
sont déplacées dans l'est plus de 10000
réunions qui ont eu lieu
on l'a vu on l'a senti dans la vente
qu'à moi sur ma circonscription il ya
une dizaine de réunions il ya dix
réunions précisément qui ont été
organisées cette que moi j'ai j'ai
organisé personnellement ou en tout cas
contribué
on a vu des réunions avec 300 400
personnes à on a vu une réunion à
montigny-le-bretonneux averse est donc
immobilisé énormément de personnes et
avec un débat avec beaucoup d'auto
régulation pour moi ça me semble
important il y avait une envie en tout
cas des personnes venues de manière
importante et qui avait envie de
débattre entre est donc ça pour moi
c'est un vrai succès alors justement va
faire le point sur ce grand débat dans
les yvelines avec notre journaliste
nicolas landry et vient nous avons
sélectionné trois communes
représentative un peu des yvelines tra
montigny le bretonneux rambouillet et
puis les communes aux alentours de
rambouillet lors des vies le plus ou
moins aisés ou défavoriser représentant
les préoccupations des zones urbaines et
rurales alors globalement il ya des
convergences notamment sur les questions
fiscales et de pouvoir d'achat
on retrouve notamment la baisse de la
tva sur les produits de première
nécessité et les personnes ont proposé
notamment de financer cette mesure
avec la hausse de la tva sur les
produits de luxe
le rétablissement de sf revient souvent
dans les propositions la réforme aussi
de l'impôt sur le revenu on retrouve
aussi des demandes sur la reconnaissance
du vote blanc et le renforcement de la
décentralisation
maintenant si on prend chaque commune
attrape il a été question d'éducation
d'emploi mais aussi de santé dans les
revendications retrouve le renforcement
du rôle des associations dans les
décisions politiques et le développement
de maisons de santé pour attirer de
nouveaux médecins
du côté de montigny le bretonneux il a
été question de transition écologique
avec la prise en compte de normes
environnementales dans la construction
de logements le sujet des retraites
aussi un film population de retraités
montigny-le-bretonneux avec la demande
de ré indexation par rapport au coût de
la vie
maintenant si on prend rambouillet belle
et propre aux préoccupations sont
forcément différentes puisque c'est non
en zone rurale et donc il souhaite le
renforcement des services publics dans
les zones rurales et l'élargissement de
l'offre de transport en commun pour
éviter l'isolément de certains villages
mais aussi pour lutter contre la
pollution alors je précise que ce sont
des propositions sélectionnées
il y en a bien d'autres évidemment ce
sont celles qui ressorte le plus dans
ces communes des yvelines
didier baichère si on revient sur les
questions fiscales parce que c'est la
principale préoccupation des français
edouard philippe l'a bien précisé
les français veulent une baisse des
impôts mais les français veulent aussi
beaucoup de service public
et forcément de la dépense publique
comment résoudre cette équation qui est
un peu paradoxale en baisse des impôts
il met beaucoup de service public
globalement dans le grand débat enfin on
retrouve beaucoup d'injection paradoxal
on peut faire plus de services publics
de manière mieux organisés avec plus de
présence sur le terrain moi je pense en
particulier à toutes les
expérimentations qui ont eu lieu sur les
maisons de service public qui nécessite
de mettre en commun plusieurs services
publics et à un moment donné quand on
peut être communes plus rurales où il ya
moins de services mais qui sont présents
donc y'a moyen de mettre en commun mais
on voit la difficulté c est mettre en
commun des services publics dans la même
maison de service public ça veut dire là
trois statuts différents de la fonction
publique même si à 3,6 strauss est très
différent et on voit là qu'on va on va
toucher un sujet de la transformation de
la fonction publique à des économies
aussi potentiellement de la fonction
publique et saissac olivier du socle le
ministre en charge est en train de
travailler et négocier avec les
organisations syndicales de la fonction
publique donc c'est pas forcément
antinomiques
moi je regarde aussi sur la fiscalité
j'ai vu qu'il y avait évidemment un
ras-le-bol fiscale mais ça c'est le
déclenchement de des gilets jaunes mais
il ya aussi beaucoup d'éléments de la
compréhension à quoi sert la fiscalité
et à quoi servent les impôts moi j'ai
des souvenirs particuliers à versailles
dans la même réunion
vous aviez ce qui était pour m l'impôt
pour tout le monde donc commencé même si
c'est un euro d'impôt à payer mais en
tout cas faire une progressivité
complète de l'impôt et des gens qui
disaient non non pas du tout faut rien
toucher et plutôt augmenter les tranches
supérieures
donc il va falloir trouver un moment
donné je pense que le point
d'atterrissage il devra aussi concerner
majoritairement les classes moyennes
c'est aussi ça qu'on va regarder sur ces
tranches des classes moyennes peut être
pour l'étendre un peu plus mais qui dit
étendre pour les classes moyennes dira
forcément qu'il faudra aller chercher
l'argent quelque part peut-être sur
l'ippi a augmenté à un moment donné va
il ya des pistes qui sont sur la table
on verra au tour d'edf moi je vous fais
un encore une fois je n'y crois pas j'ai
un avis personnel en tout cas qui je
vois pas bien l'intérêt souhait quand il
y avait lié sef les frigos était pas
plus plein c'est pas vraiment le sujet
par contre peut-être un étalement des
tranches pour que la classe moyenne soit
moins taxés ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très qui est très présent via la tva
obtient quand vous regardez les chiffres
au niveau national et honnêtement de
circonscriptions urbaines elles sont
très très proches du niveau national on
a on a des éléments quand même je parle
beaucoup de la tva peut-être les la tva
sur les produits de première nécessité
voile a cessé d éléments qui sont
présents à saint nicolas pour ces
précisions fiscale
autre point est le ressort un besoin de
transformation de changements
institutionnels comme la reconnaissance
des votes blancs
ou encore le rôle essentiel du maire
faut-il renforcer le pouvoir des
collectivités
c'est une question de pouvoir des
collectivités c'est qu'à un moment donné
cet exercice il a montré qu'il y avait
une appétence très très forte des
françaises et des français à participer
au débat
et quand vous regardez les résultats du
grand débat il parle d'ailleurs sous
tous souvent du référendum au niveau
local donc être plus impliqués dans les
décisions locales
nous on a proposé d'instaurer ce qu'on
appelle des lois des citoyennes pour
faire très très simple et la possibilité
pour un certain nombre de citoyens il
faudra définir le nombre
si collectivement ils veulent travailler
un sujet d'être en capacité de proposer
une loi plutôt que d'être sur un
référendum sur un sujet donc ça c'est
des avancées effectivement qui pourrait
qui pourrait être qui pourrait être
proposée demain j'espère en tout cas ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que le grand débat
c'est aussi quelque chose qui devra
continuer à exister
s'il ya autant de monde qui s'est
déplacé en tout cas sur sur nos communes
c'est ce qu'on a vu en particulier ma
sueur sur ma circonscription
on est on est 42e en termes de
participation au niveau français est on
est on est numéro deux dans les yvelines
donc ça veut dire que sur cette première
circonscription des yvelines
il ya une très forte appétence au débat
donc il faudra probablement que cet
exercice où les élus rendent des comptes
face aux citoyens soient poursuivis moi
je suis pour avoir un grand débat
national tous les ans par exemple nous
rendre on rendra des comptes sur notre
action au parlement chaque année auprès
des citoyens alors une des
revendications des gis les jeunes le
rythme le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne pourtant absent finalement du
grand débat mais je crois que c'est pas
quelque chose qui est sorti de manière
importante
moi j'ai entendu surtout mieux
comprendre les lois qui était travaillée
au niveau du parlement et encore une
fois ce que je disais juste avant c'est
à dire rendez-nous des comptes venez
débattre avec nous de la manière dont
vous avez mis en place les lois ce que
vous avez finalement retenu dans un
texte de loi venez en débattre avec nous
fait de la co construction et ça c'est
des éléments qu'on retiendra
probablement alors autre point de
convergence entre ce mouvement d gilet
jaune et leurs revendications et la
restitution du grand débat notamment
donc dans le secteur de la santé dans
les zones plus rurales
comment comptez-vous pallier à cette
désertification on parle beaucoup de la
diversité diversité désertification
bardon et dans les zones rurales mais
dans les zones très urbaine comme la
première circonscription des yvelines
je peux vous assurez vous avez
exactement les mêmes problématiques pour
trouver un médecin généraliste ou un
spécialiste
donc là il ya des décisions fortes qui
ont été prises qui commence par la
suppression du numerus clausus qui
n'aura effectivement pas un effet dès la
semaine prochaine mais qui dans les cinq
à dix ans pour à son effet c'est à dire
plus de médecins qui sont formés et qui
vont permettre d'irriguer beaucoup plus
les territoires ça renvoie aussi à la
question de comment en place nos
médecins dans les différents territoires
on peut pas avoir tous les médecins qui
postule en région parisienne
exclusivement est donc là dans la loi
santé il ya effectivement des éléments
qui répondent à ce point une question
ultime après la restitution de ce grand
débat le gouvernement est il vraiment en
connexion avec les attentes du peuple
français
honnêtement pour avoir fait cette
réunion sur les 10 de ma circonscription
j'ai même souhaité faire des réunions
avec les organisations syndicales
professionnelles de salariés j'ai fait
des réunions avec les jeunes
et là aussi c'est intéressant parce que
quand vous regardez le résultat des
réunions avec les jeunes on parle
beaucoup plus d'emploi de formation
d'orientation et de chômage des
inégalités liées au chômage
donc c'est très intéressant donc oui je
pense qu'on est très fortement connectés
grâce à texter grâce à cet exercice de
dialogue citoyen particulièrement le
président emmanuel macron s'exprimera
dans le courant de la semaine prochaine
pour faire connaître ses décisions
didier baichère rester avec nous on
passe tout de suite au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et on reste sur l'une des préoccupations
des français le travail à mener les
bénéficiaires du rsa à l'emploi c'est la
mission de lagence d'insertion
professionnelle du département activity
lancer en 2015 l agence compte un nouvel
adhérent saint quentin en yvelines
reportage de mélanie poquet et nicolas
d'andré activity à un nouvel adhérent
lagence d'insertion professionnelle du
département accueille depuis hier
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le territoire de saint quentin
c'est avec le territoire de la vallée de
la seine le territoire où il y à la fois
le plus grand nombre de bénéficiaires du
rsa mais aussi où il ya le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises et à dynamisme
entrepreneurial qui est très marquée une
volonté de la communauté d'agglomération
d'accompagner d'avoir une vraie
compétence emploi de la prendre à bras
le corps saint quentin en yvelines ses
dix sept mille entreprises et plus de 23
mille postes non pourvus activités
travaille sur des remises à niveau et
des qualifications deux personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
je rentre au conseil d'administration
donc déjà on va avoir un regard croisé
de notre territoire par rapport à ce que
eux ils amènent et puis nous qu'est ce
que nous pouvons apporter
on sait qu'on a des poches très complexe
au niveau des douze communes
on sait qu'on a des quartiers on avait 8
pv sur notre territoire
sur ses huit bébés on sait bien qu'il ya
des actions et qui sont menées et plutôt
bien mené il y en a d'autres qui
demandent à être revitalisé dans ces
quartiers prioritaires 5% des actifs ont
un faible niveau de qualification
saint quentin en yvelines représente
plus de 26 % de l'emploi sur le
département
didier baichère où en sommes-nous des
emplois france je le rappelle sont une
réponse aux barrières à l'emploi que
peuvent rencontrer de nombreux les
habitants des quartiers défavorisés
alors déjà la bonne nouvelle sur les
emplois france et que on a décidé de les
étendre un donc à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines faisait pas
partie du territoire d'expérimentation
sur les emplois francs donc c'est le cas
maintenant donc on va pouvoir
je veux dire en plus de l'arsenal
classique du travail qu'on peut faire
avec le plan 1000 jeunes
déjà eu l'occasion de parler en tout cas
tous faire ce travail de rapprochement
des entreprises avec l'aide de pôle
emploi est certain nombre de d'acteurs
associatifs
on va avoir maintenant l'incitation
fiscale qui est très intéressante parce
que si vous embauchez un jeune d'un
quartier politique de la ville vous avez
quinze mille euros dead qui vous est
versé si vous embaucher quelqu'un en cdi
donc ça c'est c'est un élément qui est
important je pense qu'il faut pas
minimiser les effets de l'inclusion
économique c'est à dire qu'il faut
travailler beaucoup plus avec les
entreprises pour leur faire mieux
comprendre les profils que nous avons
parce que le rsa à un moment donné c'est
un parcours compliqué et on vous allez
pas être en contact directement avec
contre une entreprise donc il ya un
travail très important à faire pour
comprendre les besoins des entreprises
et travailler cette intermédiation entre
les bénéficiaires les gens qui
recherchent un job à un moment donné et
les entreprises qui recrutent et là on a
du progrès honnêtement à faire sur ce
sur ce terrain là merci didier baichère
je le rappelle vous êtes député la
république en marge de la première
circonscription des yvelines
merci d'être venu sur le plateau que
vais faire cet été la grande question
des étudiants et lycéens ils avaient
rendez vous jeudi à bois d'arcy pour
tenter de trouver un job d'été
un forum était organisé par yveline
information jeunesse et jeunes candidats
avaient la possibilité de rencontrer des
recruteurs de divers milieux des
rencontres entre des employeurs et des
jeunes organisé par le réseau
départemental information jeunesse ce
forum jobs d'été a réuni près de 25
recruteurs dans la salle des fêtes de
bonnart si c'est vrai que c'est un pas
vers l'autonomie c'est à dire leur
première expérience professionnelle que
qui peut être qu'ils peuvent valoriser
sur leur cv
et puis pour certains c'est aussi
financièrement pouvoir financer leur
permis pouvoir financer leurs vacances
l'autre projet ces postes saisonniers
sont accessibles dès l'âge de 16 ans ce
type de forum est toujours un rendez
vous très attendu par les jeunes
travailleurs le chercheur
pour gagner l'argent et vous divertir
j'ai quasiment trois mois de vacances du
pousse à nous dépasser à rien faire en
fait dès cet été je vais devenir majeur
donc partir en vacances sans ses parents
il faut automatiquement de l'argent
différents secteurs d'activité étaient
représentées parmi les recruteurs de la
grande distribution des enseignes de
commerce l'hôtellerie-restauration et la
mairie de bois d'arcy nous commerçons un
poste en voirie donc pour les services
techniques nous recherchons quatre
quatre jeunes pour le mois de juillet
quatre jeunes pour le mois d'août la
voirie c'est autant pour les filles que
pour les garçons il faut juste être
volontaire et courageux prochain rendez
vous pour les jeunes à la recherche d'un
job d'été le 15 mai à
chanteloup-les-vignes manger mieux avec
des produits locaux la grande
préoccupation des citoyens une soirée
sur l'agriculture était organisée
mercredi à thoiry des élus des
associations ainsi que des acteurs
agricoles se sont réunis pour réaliser
un bilan sur la plaine de versailles et
imaginer les contours de l'agriculture
de demain
michael et demi d'euros les acteurs du
monde agricole yvelinois ont pris la
parole ce mercredi 10 avril au château
de thouars une centaine de personnalités
de la plaine de versets sont venus faire
un état des lieux de leur territoire à
travers des conférences
l'objectif était de faire le bilan de ce
qui a été fait depuis dix ans et se
donner des perspectives pour les
prochaines années à venir il est il est
passionnant et il demande beaucoup
d'intelligence collective
il est passionnant parce que les défis
environnementaux ils ne sont pas l'autre
bout de la planète ils sont aussi à côté
de chez nous dans la salle des élus de
27 communes de la plaine de versailles
parmi eux des hommes politiques de saint
quentin en yvelines un territoire
composé à 20 % de terres agricoles qui
compte devenir acteurs de l'agriculture
de demain saint quentin en yvelines peut
intervenir par exemple
dans le cadre de l'accompagnement pour
des nouvelles installations pour des
conversion vers l'agriculture biologique
elle peut aussi intervenir pour
favoriser le développement de points de
vente pour les circuits courts pour une
plus grande proximité entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs
elle peut aussi intervenir en
coordination avec les communes que c'est
pas sa compétence directe sur
l'alimentation locale au niveau de la
restauration collective des politiques
mais également des particuliers sont
venus à thoiry c'est le cas du fondateur
de la biscuiterie les deux gourmands
installé à crépir depuis 2012 et qui
compte aujourd'hui plus de 400 points de
vente en local
à terme j'ai vraiment la sensation qu'on
est en train de créer un endroit un lieu
un territoire qui sera à terme
exemplaire
j'en suis persuadé sur le mieux produire
et le mieux consommer le prochain bilan
de l'agriculture en plaine de versailles
est programmée pour l'année prochaine
c'est une première pour les pompiers de
magny les hameaux neuf d'entre eux se
sont rendus ce mardi sur le site du
distributeur électrique est née 10 à
guyancourt dans le cadre d'un
partenariat
michael almy d'euros les a suivis c'est
une première pour les pompiers de
magny-les-hameaux neuf d'entre eux se
sont rendus ce mardi 9 avril sur le site
du distributeur électrique est née 10 à
guyancourt dans le cadre d'un
partenariat
ils ont découvert à cette occasion un
poste source un grand transformateur qui
permet d'abaisser la tension électrique
objectif créer une coopération pour la
prévention des risques pour leur
expliquer le chemin de l'électricité à
quel moment et ben on peut être amené à
intervenir nous pour couper
l'électricité si jamais il ya un risque
important sur une zone et de quelle
façon
les pompiers pourront intervenir avec
notre appui en cas d'incident pendant la
visite les visages sont concentrés les
responsables des dix sont présentés
pendant toute la matinée les différents
secteurs de ce site qui dessert
l'électricité dans la zone de saint
quentin en yvelines et de versailles
c'est une certaine norme aimant donc
déjà de voir concrètement le site son
fonctionnement et après d'avoir un
échange avec les acteurs va dire un
échange physique avec avec les acteurs
et ça c'est toujours très intéressant
c'est un vrai plus et c'est toujours
mieux quand on comprend bien les choses
voilà et sur les interventions ça peut
nous aider également ce type de visite
est organisée une à deux fois dans
l'année dans le cadre d'un partenariat
renouvelé tous les trois ans
le soleil refera son apparition ce
week-end vous aurez peut-être lé envie
de profiter de votre jardin de lui
redonner une seconde vie
nos journalistes marie l'ania piccino et
michael et demi d'euros sont partis
recueillir pour vous des conseils
jardinage je voudrais de la lune
non jamais
d
transformer son jardin d'hiver pour le
printemps première étape son gazon pour
lui redonner un petit coup de verre un
peu d'engrais on va se créer des lignes
droites dans notre gazon c'est la baisse
et le le geste auguste du semeur le
paysagiste effectué deux passages un
premier par ligne puis dans la
perpendiculaire
cela permet une répartition homogène et
d'éviter la catastrophe
la brûlure de sa pelouse une opération a
effectué fin février et a renouvelé en
septembre pour un meilleur entretien on
voit un gazon qui repart quand même bien
il n'y a pas trop de nous parce que il
ay là il a ces deux apports d'engrais
par an et pourtant on est on est un
endroit où on a une terreur gilles ' si
la terre argileuse du bassin et du noah
n'est pas des plus propices aux gars que
je vous elle est en revanche idéal pour
les arbustes
n'hésitez pas à leur faire de la place
dans vos massifs mais avant plantation
ont l'âme ils sont injustes habillée
c'est le retail et légèrement avant la
plantation pour qui les maîtres du bois
et de la racine
une fois ces branches mortes coupe et on
peut le sortir de son pot pour vérifier
et déployer légèrement ses racines en
blanc voyez c'est un végétal qui qui se
porte très bien c'est ce qu'on appelle
des radicelles c'est à dire les
nouvelles racines et à partir de ce
moment là une présence importante de
radicelles c'est clair buste il est prêt
à s'installer et il va partir très
rapidement lorsque vous creusez une
astuce créer une cuvette pour faciliter
l'arrosage si on fait pas cette cuvette
l'eau va tomber et restera jamais au
contact de de la plante
l'idée c'est vraiment d'amener le lot à
la racine
l'idéal pour une nouvelle plantation est
un arrosage deux fois par semaine de
l'équivalent d'un seau d'eau pour sa
toute première tétée laplante a même
besoin d'un arrosage jusqu'au refus il
faut attendre ce phénomène pour pour
considérer que l'arrosage est bien
réalisé enfin n'oubliez pas vos plantes
qu'il faudra battre comme ceux romarin
qui a besoin de petites coupes
vous pouvez toujours l'égard des pros
vote premier barbecue de l'année on
passe de twittos reste de l'actualité en
ile-de-france avec nos confrères de via
grand paris
[Musique]
paris porte l'ambition d'une métropole
intelligente innovantes et stimulante
pour une nouvelle économie dans laquelle
se développent en harmonie les grands
groupes et les jeunes pousses paris
capitales européennes des start up
un reportage de nos confrères de via
grand paris clarisse merlet vient de se
lancer dans le monde du travail
ancienne étudiante à l'école nationale
d'architecturé elle a créé sa start up
son activité réutiliser le textile en
matériaux les habits récupérés sont
broyées et mélangées une colle
écologique
ils sont ensuite agglomérées pour en
faire des briques j'ai créé et développé
ce matériau qui est une brique de
textiles recyclés qui permet de faire
des cloisons isolante en acoustique et
en termine ici par les premiers clients
sont des chaînes d'hôtels ou des chaînes
de magasins pour des commandes
d'aménagement intérieur de mobilier ou
de cloisons
si le recyclage des déchets peut être
source d'innovation le secourisme aussi
en france seulement deux personnes sur
dix sont formés aux gestes qui sauvent
un retard qui donne une idée à emmanuel
bourse et il fonde avec d'autres un seul
geste
le principe se servir de la réalité
virtuelle pour former la population
on propose des formations immersive les
participants ont un masque de réalité
virtuelle sur la tête et on va les
mettre en situation
derrière ça les prépare mieux agir et le
jour où on va devoir faire peut-être un
massage cardiaque ou une position
latérale de sécurité
eh bien on va être plus à l'aise mieux
préparés parce qu'on leur a fait dans
des conditions du réel
en france les startups poussent comme
des champignons
si l'écosystème est propice à la
création d'entreprise l'accompagnement
reste un enjeu crucial pour les start up
qui veulent prospérer paris enhco est un
incubateur qui gère 14 programme
d'incubation
nous on a accompagné les navires +450
start up en 2018
elles ont levé plus de 200 millions
d'euros pendant l'année 2018 donc c'est
vraiment des chiffres assez
extraordinaire et une tendance en
croissance par rapport à l'année
précédente
aujourd'hui plus de 10000 start up
innovantes en france en 2022
elle pourrait être plus de 12000 et
créer 400 mille emplois
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo vous
pouvez retrouver l'émission en replay
sur notre site internet tv 78 points
comme retour de l'information lundi dans
le 7-8 journal à 18 heures et d'ici là
passez un excellent week end
[Musique]